for the first time we are seeing an
image of one of the most mysterious and
fascinating corners of the universe this
black hole has a six and is has six and
a half a billion times the mass of our
Sun that's so mind-boggling it's hard to
even read it is devouring the insides of
a galaxy about 55 million light years
away
mark Strassmann is at the Smithsonian
National Air and Space Museum in
Washington DC with why it took 8
telescopes to capture this image mark
good morning good morning major
milestone for cosmologists black holes
are the most powerful vacuum in the
universe they inhale everything even
light for eternity but as menacing as
they seemed until now they've been
invisible fortune even horizon this
scene from interstellar was thought to
be the most realistic movie depiction
ever of a black hole table turns out
Hollywood's fantasy was close to reality
when we saw this coming to focus our
jaws dropped astrophysicist Shep Dolman
leads an international team of
scientists that unveiled this image a
circular silhouette against the glow of
superheated matter swirling into its
dark abyss it's a cosmic first visual
proof of the supermassive black hole
nearly 25 billion miles across almost
the size of our solar system in the
center of a nearby galaxy called Messier
87 I think that this image will be an
important part of astronomy going
forward for years to come we're getting
closer and closer to the edge of
oblivion humbling to know that these
monsters exist that is humbling
cosmologists believe black holes are
born when a colossal object like a
super-sized star dies and collapses in
on itself the result is a bottomless
sinkhole were all known laws of physics
fall apart and just like in the movies
they're irresistible gravitational pull
swallows anything that sprays too close
capturing the historic image was said to
be like spotting a donut on the surface
of the Moon scientists had to
synchronize eight radio telescopes on
four continents for imaging teams on
supercomputers needed two years to
crunch all the data it's amazing to me
that we can see a supermassive black
hole in the heart of a galaxy fifty-five
million light years away you can't make
that up scientists now believe there's a
black hole spinning in nearly every
galaxy including ours and the same team
was working on an image of that one and
they could come out of that image very
soon
Gail all right mark Strassmann thank you
very much
so interesting how the Hollywood
depiction looks so much like what it
really is what are you learning about
the person who's behind it no so MIT is
computer science and artificial lab
tweeted this yesterday the three years
ago an MIT grad student Katie Bowman led
the creation of this new algorithm that
led to this first picture and so many
people are saying this morning take your
seat among history and of course she
said it was a lot of us that worked
together to get this done I'm very
excited you go women in stem all right
go Katie Bowman ahead and her team